podcast as always I'm your host Paul AKA
shilliam Shatner writer of this
shillenium Falcon shillium Shakespeare
Hillary Clinton Hillary Duff shillery
puff piece that we're going to be
talking about here because we've got
lots of news about chills uh critics the
conspiracy theories are about to unfold
but I'm here with YouTube's biggest
chill if you read the comments Greg Alba
from real rejects how's it going baby
it's going well Paul you you me you
brought me my first smile today I
appreciate it I love the difference in
our cameras I'm gonna be like hey man
that's good like you're so much lower
than me right now I was trying to adjust
it and rolling hey hey Paul because
people keep saying that we're holding
hands all the time so I wanna avoid the
rumors get in trouble off the wife she's
like why you son of a [__] no man that
was the one thing that gave me Pride was
the perception that people were having
of us I think we should ask up front if
you're listening to us on Apple and
Spotify please leave us a rating we got
advice earlier to say that and I felt
like we should throw that out there the
first thing I want to dive into is the
fact that Warner Brothers
um they've said that they're going to be
taking a hit of between 300 million to
500 million dollars in their 2023
earnings because apparently according to
David's aslab it's because of the
strikes going on at the moment in
Hollywood as we know there's of course
writer strikes actor strikes everyone's
on strike and yeah zazzy after a couple
of weeks ago bragging that the company
had saved 100 million dollars due to not
paying the actors he's back and he's
going actually we've nearly lost half a
billion dollars it's not going well
um what are your thoughts on it Greg is
it time to make a deal maybe maybe
getting so time to make a deal I mean
it's kind of bizarre because they have
the biggest movie of the year which
they've even been pushing the video the
Barbie which they've even been pushing
the video on demand release they're
supposed to come out a couple weeks ago
and it's supposed to come out last week
but it's still been doing well in the
theaters so they're like you know what
let's push the video on demand release
just feel like they did it the day of
because they're trying to milk that cash
cow as much as possible because that
seems to be the one thing that's
behooving them I wonder how much they're
trying to lump all of it into the strike
situation because yes the strike
affecting everybody it's affecting
everyone all around
um and I'm sure yeah they totally lost
money uh because a lot because a lot of
it comes down to like here was what they
expected to earn and now because they
can't release certain things and the
cost of delays and whatnot so now it's
like okay we won't earn this much and
we're we're losing money by not go going
forward with releasing this or filming
this blah blah blah uh but at the same
time you know they did lose a bunch of
money with films like The Flash and Blue
Beetle both lost a a really good chunk
of change flash one of the biggest flops
um of comic book movie history
and it's it sucks for them but you know
it's not a huge surprise they have the
don't they have the uh the video game
strike situation that is on the horizon
as well and Warner Brothers games I'm if
I'm not mistaken will also be lumped
into that category if they do move
forward with that so Warner Brothers
really needs to get their [__] together
because they could be sitting out to
lose even more money and have an even
bigger effect three to five hundred
million that's a lot of dough what were
the writers originally projected to it
was like in the 400 million dollar range
wasn't it like the four or 450 million
range
I mean if they'd negotiated the strikes
it would have been less money than
they've lost and they would have been
back to work I'm actually really
surprised that they haven't hammered
things down with the actors yet because
as we saw at the start of the strikes
obviously you know when the writers went
on strike things you know were a bit
difficult on set but they could at least
still film and go forward with things
whereas when the actors went on strike
everything stopped so it's just been
completely mothballed and I thought
straight away well they're gonna try and
negotiate with the the actors as quickly
as possible because that's going to at
least allow them to go back to work you
know I mean a movie set isn't just
actors either it's directors cameramen
crew lighting blah blah blah all that
um and those people aren't working at
the moment either so I thought straight
away are they going to want to get the
actors stuff negotiated but they haven't
um and in terms of the video game thing
it's mainly for voice actors and
obviously they do a lot of motion
capture these days I mean for example if
you are behind the scenes on even
something from 10 years ago like the
last of us they they were doing a lot of
motion capture on that apparently from
what I've been reading
um performance capture in a video so
apparently from what I've been reading
performance capture in a video game is
only roughly about five percent of it
and so
you know it's not going to be the case
where we've seen films getting delayed a
lot of the work on video games can still
be done because it's people working on
desks and actually building a game and
then at the end or either during it they
bring in the performance so they're not
massively going to be stalled on it but
there is going to likely be a strike in
that industry I'm not 100 on it but I
don't think it's going to affect
the video game industry and delay stuff
as much as we've seen with films but
losing that amount of money I mean I
kind of agree with what you're saying I
think they would have lost that money
anyway because they've had so many bombs
and I think rather than admitting that
they've made a lot of terrible mistakes
in terms of what they've done with DC
and so on and we'll talk about Aquaman
later on but I think rather than
admitting that they've just pinned it
all on the strikes and but it does sound
like you know the shareholders might
hear that and think oh well you guys
should go negotiate which they
definitely should
um and yeah hopefully that kind of gets
the ball rolling on things they've been
hit with this massive loss after
bragging that they saved 100 million
dollars they've also it's gotten public
how much it's going to cost to negotiate
the deal and it's not anywhere near half
a billion dollars that they would have
lost so I think they're going to realize
like we need to get things in place
because the clock is ticking 2024 is
just around the corner which is quite
scary and they're going to be looking at
more losses likely due to how much
they've stored things and how little
money that's going to be coming through
the door because all these projects are
going to be delayed for so long well I
you know I live in LA so I I I'm really
in the heart of seeing just how many
people's jobs have been affected because
you know it's beyond just the writers
and actors there's a whole bunch of
people on production who are having to
sell their houses and or try to get
second jobs and whatnot like it's been
really really rough out here and another
conversation that's been going on is
that the holidays are coming up so in a
lot of ways for for many people what
ends up happening around this season in
La when it when it comes to shooting is
they don't even really shoot stuff
um like a couple months from now they
don't even really shoot stuff or even
pick up projects and whatnot because or
pick up new material because everyone's
going on holiday and they really plan
around that sure some stuff is being
shot we got like a billion projects and
whatnot but the really big Monumental
things they really do structure their
shooting schedules around allowing
people to have their holiday time with
their families and everything so they it
just kind of behooves them to wait like
the studios I mean the maybe not the not
the working people we're putting the
films together for the studios it it
behooves them in a way your way to just
wait till 2024 to actually pick it back
up so it could be one of their one of
their many tactics it's funny because
zazlov was one he had a different tune
than you know Bob Iger when it came to
the strikes he was the one saying he was
the one saying that it's gonna you know
we have a plan and we feel like we can
get this resolved by September and it's
we've made like almost no progress here
yeah and it's not going to get to
resolved any time it doesn't feel like
it's going to get resolved anytime soon
at least yeah which is strange because I
was looking into it and I'm sure these
deals only last three years anyway so I
mean they're gonna have to negotiate it
again in 2026 6 and I was thinking why
not write just agree to the demands
right now just agree to them and then
you've got three years to kind of plan
and negotiate things and go back to
saying well this has worked out this
hasn't um we're gonna have to cut in
certain areas rather than just delaying
it and completely messing up the
schedule for what's likely going to be
about two years I'd say I mean by the
time this gets resolved and things get
put back into production and then things
get released we're probably going to be
hitting the at the end of the uh the
deal anyway so if it was me I would just
do it and another thing is I know the
studios are all part of their their own
group as well but I don't know why one
of them's not fractured off and being
like well like we've seen with a24 they
agree to all the terms straight away in
their in production right now and
shooting films and stuff I don't know
why someone like Disney or Warner
Brothers didn't just say well we go
we'll go negotiate with them separately
we'll agree to it we'll come out looking
like the good guys all our stuff's gonna
get put into production We're Not Gonna
okay we're gonna hit a point where all
these other studios I've messed about
they're gonna be hit with delays and
we're gonna have like a clear calendar
and a lot of time to release stuff when
they're still kind of fumbling about so
yeah it's a bit strange that they've all
kind of done it this way yeah but it's
not all doom and gloom there has been
some good stuff and Netflix is one piece
opened up to 18.5 million in its first
three days and it's still at the number
one spot in 86 countries which hell yeah
no we talked last week about the Ahsoka
viewing figures which were 14 million or
15 million depending on who you ask or
1.4 million depending on who you ask uh
but yeah for Netflix to do that it's
really good um and it's a it's a
brilliant show I think um it's kind of
opened the door almost I like we I know
we've always said once the comic book
movie genre dies out what we're gonna
see is video game adaptations I actually
think and I said this in my one piece
review I think anime adaptations might
be the way forward we might finally get
a good live-action Death Note which I
would actually love I don't know if you
can see it Greg I've got got all the
Death Note books over there but yeah I
have one of my favorite runs of anything
of all time ever oh hell yeah I didn't
know that yeah no Death Note honestly
changed my life reading that um and
hopefully we get that would be my dream
if we're getting good live action death
now put me in charge of it
um but yeah Greg what were your thoughts
on one piece I know you're kind of
running through reactions on the episode
so far where are you up to and what
you're thinking I I finished it um I
loved it I loved it a lot I've never
seen the anime personally
um but I I there's a lot of anime I love
uh you know like actually this year I
read
I read all of Attack on Titan up until
where because there's like one more
special episode to release that will
conclude the series and I've stopped the
reading up to that point because I
didn't I was like oh I don't want that
part to get ruined because it's a pretty
faithful adaptation and I would like to
just watch the show because I so yeah I
mean adapting adapting anime or Manga
whatever it may be I think if the one
thing that's been a true Testament you
know Mario is a movie that's been a
great success for everyone great it's
success it's been a great success for
everyone uh but when it comes to a lot
of these adaptations it's been very
apparent because for the longest time
you know I I'm one of the many people
who as well who have said that video
games if you're going to adapt them the
best way to do that would be if you're
gonna adapt the world to video games
best way to do that would be a
television series and especially in this
Golden Age television that we have you
know last of us really prove that you
can do it Arcane really proved that you
could really do it you know and Mario of
course being a really successful film as
well I feel like if there was a Mario
show I don't feel like we would have
complained about that either and then of
course with anime yeah no it just it
makes sense is the big problem that
always come down to these feature films
is to try to condense all this [__] into
one movie or try to put all this lore
and if we're trying to also set up the
future it would be hard to isolate
things but like there was all that talk
about potentially Andy muschietti
adapting Attack on Titan into a feature
film
I don't think you should do that like I
just don't I don't feel like that's the
the way to go about it Death Note uh I
would say kind of the same thing I mean
is there a world where you can pull that
off when it's sort of a limited series
run yes absolutely you can pull off like
a two to three film uh type of deal but
a lot of times they wanted to do that
with Elita battle Angel a movie that I
actually quite enjoyed in spite of
seeing the very apparent flaws to it one
of them being getting a little too
bogged down with World building and a
little too bogged down we're trying to
set up the future and the film
ultimately didn't perform up to the
metrics that they were hoping for
and I think going the route of
Television is an awesome way to do it
and at the same time when you're
thinking about Netflix it just popped
into my head too is that you know back
to the previous story of like the studio
the studios making the other agreements
uh like a Disney being like yeah we're
gonna go off and do our own thing go
into production what not get a head
start the I think the issue though is
like when it comes to like interim
agreements is that yeah they can go into
production but then what happens when
you put
um like that movie on Netflix for
streaming because first we're talking
about Netflix reminding me about how
Aaron Paul just came out and he was
speaking on how Breaking Bad which is a
show I did discover via Netflix as I did
not have AMC
he hasn't seen a dime in residuals off
of
um off of that as well and what's crazy
is I'm starting to wonder for a show
like one piece a phenomenal massive hit
how the people involved the actors and
the writers obviously
if they they must not have had some deal
in place you know to be getting the
residual earnings off of one of
Netflix's now biggest shows of all time
and it's that strange thing where it's
like yeah we can celebrate the success
of the show and seeing the success of
the writers and the actors the cast was
phenomenal in this series as well
and I am here curious like what is the
what is the feeling that some of them
are having right now though of oh do
they feel like that yeah it's success
but not going to be reaping the
additional rewards that they feel like
they deserve to be and and the rewards
that they they do deserve to be
receiving as well got to bring it back
to that yeah you know we'll see what
this strikes negotiating if things get
changed around because it does sound
like they are actors are getting screwed
out of stuff even big ones like Aaron
Paul you know obviously it's it's
difficult to sympathize with the guy
because he's a famous multi-millionaire
who's been in lots of big things but you
know it take Aaron Paul out of it and
just apply it to a lesser-known actor
and you can kind of see where there's
issues on it now there's also been a lot
of issues in the our sort of Industry at
the moment because
um vulture put out a report talking
about Rotten Tomatoes and how uh easy it
was to game the system
it's it's basically a story that I'm
sure you've heard it's been very very
sensationalized
um weirdly the expose doesn't mention
Disney or Warner Brothers but I feel
like they've been pulled into it it's
kind of I mean let's be honest there's
been conspiracy theories for years that
Disney and Warner Brothers pay critics I
mean even ones about how Disney paid
critics to hate DC movies and you know
give sex Snyder films bad scores and
stuff there's lots of stuff like that
and I think people have just been
waiting for a while because it's
something that they've suspected that
critics get paid
um and then this story's dropped it's
when absolutely insane
um to me when I read it you know it
doesn't really mention any of the big
studios to be honest and it also to me
didn't really throw much shade on Rotten
Tomatoes but it did talk about how their
systems were easy a game and manipulate
and basically
also talking about how it's flawed that
they hold a lot of power in Hollywood
these days and Studios hate them and
they're kind of victim to if a film's
Rotten or fresh on Rotten Tomatoes and
there's a lot of stuff to break down now
obviously we are critics well I don't
like to call myself a Critic really but
call myself more and an explainer a
breakdown era but um yeah there's lots
of things that are going on with it uh I
thought it would just be interesting to
kind of work through the article the
story talk about our own experiences
with things
um how we feel the industry works as a
whole and you know try and break it down
with some new ones and just be like
movie studios pay critics to give Black
Widow positive score or something like
that
[Music]
um
so just going to the article itself
it was basically it said that there's a
PR company called bunker 15 who
apparently took a project called Ophelia
which was a feminist retelling of Hamlet
starring Daisy Ridley
um that actually got screened early for
critics there was 13 reviews seven of
which were negative which translated to
a score of 46 on Rotten Tomatoes which
as I'm sure you know equals rotten now
apparently what this PR team did is that
they contacted certain critics
um and basically you know there are
rumors that there was offers of 50 or
more for each review
um although you know Rotten Tomatoes
itself prohibits reviewing based on
financial incentives and just in general
I think if you're a Critic you should
not accept money for for any kind of
review even if it's not like I've had
some Studios contact me and they've not
necessarily said we will pay you to do a
review but they've said we want you to
review the film and we will also pay you
to say run a competition that will
entice people in and pull them towards
watching our film and it doesn't matter
if your reviews positive or negative but
you know this is that you have to do
this little thing and I always feel like
that's kind of I just feel like as soon
as I say that I'm kind of like uh and
then ethically I just always turn it
down which is why you'll probably not
see a review of Ophelia on my channel
but it wasn't them who contacted me but
there was some studios we weren't even
the big ones to be honest that kind of
said like we're looking to promote the
film we'd love for you to review on your
channel and you can also do something
where you give stuff away and will pay
you for that promotion sorry it feels
like uh it feels like those Hollywood
Mafia talks where they're not saying
like the movie they're not saying
recommend it
but you really get the impression that's
what they're actually implying yeah I've
had plenty of offers too yeah and I
think the issue with it is is you kind
of have to ask yourself I would never
accept money for it um and as much as we
get called chills
um I think you can just tell like not to
be like oh we're very fair in Euro I
think when you look at a channel
um people that I gravitate towards
whether I agree or disagree with their
opinion or not they'll have reviews
where they say something positive about
a film but then that you'll they'll also
be negative films now we know there's
channels out there that just do nothing
but negative reviews slam and rip films
apart and there's also channels out
there that do positive nothing but
hyping up films and saying how great
they are and I think if you're looking
for someone you could trust like most of
the podcasts I listen to I don't even
agree with them maybe 50 of the time but
the fact that I know they like certain
things and the fact that they like don't
like other things that makes me feel
that they're at least being genuine and
whether I agree with their opinion or
not they're still gonna give me an
opinion from an honest Place rather than
feeling like they're swayed or you know
something's been put on them by the
studio and I feel like if just if you
are a Craig and you might build your
channel up to a point where you do get
hit with a review where they're like you
you should really say something nice
about this film ask yourself how which
is your integrity worth because as we
discussed before you know they said
fifty dollars and you have to put a
price on everything because I feel if
you ever get discovered if this ever
comes out about you that is your entire
reputation and integrity and channel and
your business destroyed and you have to
ask yourself worst case scenario if all
this comes out is it worth at all
crumbling down for fifty dollars and I'm
gonna guess 100 of the time you're gonna
say no
um and yeah I feel like you know if you
get offered something you should always
just go in with that mentality if
something happens and say this gets torn
and I get exposed for this for accepting
money it seemed like a good idea at the
time but is it worth your entire
business and livelihood getting
destroyed personally I don't think it is
um but you that's a question you have to
ask yourself so it turns out anyway that
this bunker 15 allegedly uh we'll
probably have to say that for legal
reasons
um they actually message some critics
saying about Ophelia it's a Sundance
Film and the feeling is that there's be
that it's been treated a bit harshly by
some critics in Brackets I'm sure
sky-high expectations were the culprit
so the teams involved feel like it would
benefit but run more input from
different critics now from more input
it's basic basically what vulture are
saying is uh more input from different
critics is subtly saying that critics
with a certain perspective that are
gonna write positive things about this
film
um that's kind of what they're looking
for now bunker 15 allegedly according to
the report said that journalists were
free to write whatever they liked but
that's super nice reviews would often
agree not to publish so they'd often
agree not to publish bad reviews on
their usual website and in instead they
would if they were going to say
something bad they would do it on a
smaller blog site that likely wouldn't
get picked up by Rotten Tomatoes and
therefore it wouldn't affect the score
so basically what you're doing is you're
cherry picking
positive reviews to appear on Rotten
Tomatoes which boosts the score up and
any negative reviews won't get picked up
by Rotten Tomatoes and therefore it
won't bring the score down and that's
basically what they apparently done
according to um vulture
yeah and it would basically it would
help Ophelia gain I mean how many of
Greg be honest when you see a film that
you haven't heard of before do you
Google it and check what the Rotten
Tomatoes score is because I know if me
and my wife are sat watching something
yeah yeah first thing I do if I don't
know it I'll Google it and in on Google
one of the first things that'll come up
is the IMDB score and the Rotten
Tomatoes score so yeah this likely you
know would have got people to watch that
movie and I was also reading that
shortly after this
um a distributor who according to this
IFC films announced that they'd acquired
Ophelia for release in the US so this
also helped with the distribution which
likely would have been boosted by the
score now this is all kind of
you know we don't we can't say for
definite that the Rotten Tomatoes score
helped it but having it having the
system game like this it's not really a
good look and yeah obviously there's
it's been sensationalized like I said
people have jumped on it used it to
maybe tout some conspiracy theories but
there definitely is that idea now Greg
you've been a premieres before let's be
honest do premieres affect
reactions and reviews being honest I see
it I see it because the a Premiere is
the ultimate celebration of a film
because the filmmakers are there the
cast is there they usually have like if
it's a Marvel movie you'll probably have
Kevin feige come out and present
something
people are there in Cosplay in fact when
you usually what especially for Marvel
what they usually do is they have a
section where they bring a bunch of
cosplayers by
so you know there are people who just
love Marvel of the hardcore fans
and then there's this giant Podium that
is being broadcasted live even onto
YouTube where the cosplayers are around
and that that's the energy they're
hoping to Emit and then by the time the
Marvel logo shows up when cast members
are being everyone's cheering and
hootering and hollering and again I
bring it back to like I I had been to
um a few a couple like I think the I've
been to two premieres prior to Thor love
and Thunder
and I saw I went to eternals I went to
shangshi which I I really enjoyed but I
went to a they put me on the the uh I
wasn't with the actual with the cast and
stuff I was in this like smaller theater
and so I was able to just resorted the
film for what it was I appreciated that
and then uh we saw eternals which is not
really the hood ring and hollering film
and I was always able to walk out of
that and be really honest about my
disappointment with that movie
and then the third one was Thor love and
thunder which we all know the reception
to and at that Premiere you know it was
that was such a journey for me to go on
specifically and like I I'm appreciative
when I can go to a Premiere and I've
gotten better at separating myself from
audience members like I felt it which is
because even Shazam free of the Gods
went to the premiere of that so much
cheering throughout and I was like I
don't really like this movie I was I was
able to like confidently feel that
because the store 11 Thunder was the
biggest experience for me where I saw
the effect of it because I wasn't really
laughing but everyone else was really
laughing the whole time I really loved
this the last half I'll still stand by I
enjoyed the last half of that movie all
right I don't get crap for that I'll
still stand by that yeah I'll get crap
whatever
um but I enjoyed the last half of that
movie quite a bit because the second
time I saw it I saw it with like pretty
much not really a crowd on opening
weekend uh like a 12 p.m show
I was like yeah you know I actually got
a lot of issues this move but the first
time I watched it I did feel that effect
from the crowd and then you go online
and everyone's like you know it's the
greatest thing in the world right
um and even like quantumania I didn't go
to premiere for that I I actually opted
for the screen just the screening for
that didn't go to the premiere and and I
went to the screening for that and I
um I was able to come out with a very
honest opinion which was very
contradictory towards what people at the
premiere were saying
and then you cut to a couple weeks later
when Rotten Tomatoes comes out with uh
you know their score and it's not good
and
you that right there was like oh thank
God because sometimes it can be such a
because you go online and you see how a
Premiere has such an influence on there
and you know there is this weird
rhetoric that I I see from all these
people there where they no one's and one
one thing that I'm very adamant about
because I've worked with several
publicists is that I need to maintain my
honesty I have to maintain my honesty uh
no matter what and if that means you
remove me from a list because I'm honest
I'm like good because I wouldn't want to
go invited to your [__] if I feel like I
have to like your thing to be invited
like then that that messes with my
integrity and that messes with my uh the
thing I care first and foremost about is
you know my business my channel and all
that and if I can't be honest then I
don't want to I don't wanna go to your
early screenings there's no point
but there is this Vibe where and where a
lot of people they do feel
that there is this pressure
to say only positive things like not
everyone feels it but I've interacted
with plenty of people where they feel
like they have a harder time being
honest and then they also get scared
because they're out of Premiere and they
feel that reaction and going off of
Rotten Tomatoes
you know I've had a conversations with
there's one debate that I got into with
a with a publicist about it and he
actually really opened my eyes because I
was always under the impression that a
movie trailer was and and there's an
argument I think to be made that a movie
trailer is more impactful than a Rotten
Tomatoes score because you know
sometimes like even Super Mario Brothers
did not wind up it had really fun early
social media reactions but it didn't
open up with a good Rotten Tomato score
and it did a billion dollars the and it
did it in a phenomenal opening weekend
as well on the flip side you get a movie
like Mission Impossible dead reckoning
which I like the trailer but the movie
really underperforms starting from
opening weekend which had a great
audience score and a great Rotten Tomato
score
the thing though is
Studios
it's like I've gotten too much
confirmation about this at the end of
the day movie studios
really do they are victim to the belief
that Rotten Tomatoes is the end-all
be-all of everything they really do
adhere to that and it's because you know
it's a lot of times we talk about how
yeah you know in our Circle but what is
the general audience think in our Circle
what is the general audience think the
thing is is that the general audience
there's more people plugged in to Rotten
Tomatoes than we actually might think
like that they get
you know if you Google it sometimes the
numbers are different it's like Samba
versus the Ahsoka Disney numbers
sometimes when you're like oh they get
20 million viewers a month they get 80
million viewers enough I've heard
different numbers for them it's like 20
to 80 million right bottom line is
that's not just a niche little movie
circle like these the general audience
gets plugged into and a lot of people
they do make their decisions off of it
like Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny the studio really believes that
it's because of what happened at
Sundance that that really affected the
box office run of Indiana Jones and dial
Destiny goes to Sundance gets a shitty
ass score because you're playing this
kind of movie with a very specific crowd
where that's not the place you want to
play the movie and then it's just
sitting idly you know with that Rotten
Tomato score before other screenings
happen for several weeks so the the the
general opinion is it's not a good movie
because it hasn't had the time to have
the game and so what publicists often
have to do is
when they're talking about manipulating
the Rotten Tomatoes system
it's like you can call manipulation you
can call it business tactics whatever it
may be right is that depending on what
the project is eventually they're going
to let everyone see it right eventually
they'll let everyone see it
um
but let's like take let's take Warner
Brothers for example I can confidently
say Warner Brothers never invites me to
an early screening for some reason
unless it's a comic book movie because
they know my audience they know what
real rejects is often really Associated
for I didn't get invited to Barbie like
everyone else I didn't get there's all
these other things that I just don't get
invited for but you know the these comic
book movies are like they're hoping that
I'm just gonna like it you know as and
it could be part of that crowd for it
and that's where they try to manipulate
it is going like okay rotted Tomatoes is
everything and what matters is that
first score because we see it on social
media too that ah Blue Beetle debuted to
100 out of six on Rotten Tomatoes when a
lot of times it might just be like six
reviews up there might not be a lot of
reviews so there is a game that they do
play it and I guess the question is you
know a lot of people will still come I
know people are probably already typing
in the com box that Rotten Tomatoes
doesn't matter form your own opinion I
agree I I fullheartedly agree with that
bottom line is Studios uh don't agree
with uh Studios don't have that belief
and
at the end of the day there are still
millions of people probably
who will adhere to oh Rotten Tomatoes
gave it a bad review I don't really care
about this you know and so it is
influential Rotten Tomatoes is very very
much influential and it does I agree
with the criticism that it does lose a
lot of the Nuance of film criticism
because I myself feel like there's
there's a handful of people that I will
listen to and I'll listen to you
um I'll listen to uh you know Double
Toasted stuckman John's uh harloff oh
yeah I might even check out a campy of
video
um and then you know like a cosmonaut
variety hour red letter media like
there's a Dan Merle like I'll listen to
these people but most of the people
around Tomatoes I'm not gonna I'm just
gonna look at their capsule you know and
and it is easy to manipulate it because
if like everyone gives it a 3.5 Stars
which is not the most Glo like a three
star or something I don't know it might
not be the most glowing review but it
could still wind up with like a hundred
percent or in the 90s even if it's not
like overwhelmingly like glowing so I do
agree with some of this but the part of
it and I know I've been going on a
tangent here the part of it that I
I don't like about this article is the
way it's been sensationalized the way
it's spun to make it like because the
second this came out all I heard before
I read the article was see like everyone
just accused the Snyder fans of being
like crazy or something everyone was
just jumping on the the preconceived
beliefs and the shitty part of what
happened here is that yes there was a
manipulative thing that bunker 15 did
was not cool of how they handle this
Noah you should not take money for
reviews uh you shouldn't do it I've
turned down plenty I've turned down like
a lot of like sometimes they offer like
stupid money which usually means it's
not a good movie A lot of the time if
they're offering that much money and so
it's like yeah don't ex there's so don't
accept it and it what sucks is it it
messes with everyone else who is honest
you know on that like everyone who does
really just care to be an honest
reviewer and then it messes with their
with the Optics of them just being on
that website now and there's plenty of
people there who I do trust some there's
a couple people I do personally know and
I haven't talked to them about this
but I hate how it messes with with that
of
the people who already have to defend
themselves that they are just being
honest because you know how it is for
for us we've said it countless times if
we love something we're chills if we
don't like something we're paid not to
like it or we're following a crowd or or
we're influenced by someone else's
opinion you know like that's that's
always the way it goes is if you don't
love something when you were like like
especially for a series if you're
enjoying a series and suddenly you end
up like I have issues with this you got
influenced by someone else instead of it
just being your honest thing when a lot
of times I feel like it's a it's a fight
for just keep maintaining your integrity
and honesty this is a subject that I
actually did find myself very very
compelled by and uh thank you for
listening to me monologue here I
appreciate it yeah so I think that it
I think the studios definitely do game
the system 100 I mean we even see it in
the case of you know Disney will send
out early access to say the first two
episodes of a Disney Plus show because
those are the good ones and you'll see
the Rotten Tomatoes score will be very
positive for those first two episodes
um and even something like Ahsoka I I
would swear down that I was one of a
handful of people who was saying these
first two episodes are quite dragged out
very slow paced and there's not really
you know they're not that exciting and
interesting and then you know everyone
was kind of all the early reactions were
saying how great it was and then when
the episodes released a lot of people
were echoing my thoughts I know a lot of
people liked it I actually think the
show has gotten a lot better as it's
went on and but I feel like those people
are kind of not necessarily Cherry
Picked but they know these guys are
going to be more in favor of our work
and therefore they're going to make it
look better and that'll get people more
excited so I feel like rotten tomatoes
in general and reactions are just
another armored Market rather than being
necessarily specific to
give a fair representation of something
and I think you know Studios do that I
think just putting myself in the
position of someone who has been through
it all as well I think when you when
you're first starting out with someone
reviewing films you know it's the dream
to get invited to premieres and go to
them and you know get to see things
before everyone else and write about
movies and people see that and I can I
actually I was trying to think off the
top of my head and I don't think this
will be the case but I can imagine that
every time someone's been invited to
something for the very first time that
they would have given a positive review
it doesn't because they didn't want to
mess up that opportunity that they've
been waiting for for years and years and
they probably would have said well I'll
be nice and not mess it up with the pr
people
um and I've always kind of just removed
myself from that I I used to get invited
to stuff
um and I've just hit a point now where I
just don't I always decline it because I
just don't want my opinion to be swayed
by that and I do feel like I feel like
I'm self-aware enough to not be swayed
by that and I will give my honest
opinion on stuff but even if there's a
chance that say the glitz and glamor of
meeting my hero Angelina Jolie or
something say that swayed me into saying
a movie was great
I feel that would be a disservice to me
um and uh even if there's like a one
percent chance that I could be victim of
that I have to take it as an absolute
certainty
um and I think
I think with the Rotten Tomatoes in
general I think a lot of people rely on
it they talk about it they obsess over
the scores you know when it when a score
for a new film drops that's the first
talking point everyone obsesses over the
score on social media to decide whether
something's good or bad without even
seeing it themselves and I feel that
deep down
people don't like doing that and they
almost want to see Rotten Tomatoes
destroyed because it's such a I think
people feel like the entire movie
industry on both as a fan is both a
studio and so on I think everyone feels
like they're almost victim to this and
they do want to see it torn down and I
think articles like this definitely push
that narrative and help to do it and I
personally don't like as much as I use
Rotten Tomatoes I personally don't like
the way that it is and I don't really
like it because I don't feel like it's a
it's a good representation of what a
movie can truly be I mean a lot of the
time if it's a general pop flick
um something that's you know not uh
that's going to be mainstream for
everyone I think you know the score
might be right but say my favorite film
of the year is infinity pool which is a
10 out of 10 for me but for some people
it's going to be a two out of ten and
those more Niche movies I don't feel
like rotten tomatoes works for it
because you you have things that are
shown for to certain audiences
um and people just aren't going to
connect with it in a way that I would
and I'll absolutely love that film and
it took a long time for me to actually
see infinity pool because of reviews
putting me off and as much as I love the
director and the cast I just felt like
seeing the Rotten Tomatoes scores and
stuff like that I mean it's got a pretty
good score but it wasn't really
hammering at home to be like oh this is
a must-see for you Paul this is just
like an okay movie and I don't feel like
it captures that new once you know it's
either rotten or it's
um good or freshly so it's either rotten
or fresh and that's it that's all it
boils down to a very binary score where
it's either good or bad there's not that
Nuance to be like well this part of it
wasn't that good but this actor really
shot in it they completely knocked it
out the park
um just for their performance alone you
should watch it there's not that level
of nuance to it and it's not a case of
like well did you like this movie you're
gonna like this one it's kind of just
but very much this is good or this is
bad yeah and you know dial of Destiny I
think is the perfect example you know it
was shown to a certain audience and
where it got negative reviews completely
killed it and it was sat there for ages
and
whoever's decision it was to
Premiere it there and have the review
embargo lift at the same time
that was so stupid because it was so far
out and we saw this with the case of the
flash as well where reactions happen so
far out and it's then going to maintain
that hyper so long and makes it really
difficult for a film to do
um and I think like just in general you
just can't use Rotten Tomatoes as a good
aggregate because it can be gamed as
we've seen But even then when it's not
gamed you know some stuff's written for
critics to do well the Last Jedi is a
perfect example 91 on Rotten Tomatoes
but absolutely hated by so many people
however if you were an alien who just
came down from space and was like I need
to catch up on human culture I'm gonna
look up the best films from the last 10
years you know Last Jedi would be on
there and because
it's going off that score that doesn't
quite capture new ones and what people
like how they feel a place into a
franchise how they feel it plays off the
back of the history all the things going
on with Star Wars for example Disney
buying it and how they've changed
certain characters and got certain
directors and and instead it boils all
that down to a very binary score that
can be gained we we've seen it and you
know it might be a very rare case where
I've never heard of Bunker 15 or bunker
51 or whatever they were called up
totally forgot already uh that's not a
good sign of my memory but yeah it's um
it's it's just something that can be
gained and you know Studios have done it
themselves we've I know Captain Marvel
was getting review bombed and there was
a lot of negative score but there was a
controversy at the time where the
studios
or Rotten Tomatoes stepped in and
retracted a lot of scores so that it
bumped up the the final score for the
film and just when it can be game like
that you know
it shows that it shouldn't really have
the final say of whether a film's good
and it shouldn't have as much power as
it does because if a studio can game it
by either sending out screeners to
certain people or cherry picking
reviewers or only doing certain episodes
that get reviewed to decide to score or
even contacting reviewers to put posts
on certain websites that can then boost
it over it's just it's all over the
place and yeah I think it's it might not
have necessarily been an expose on
Rotten Tomatoes itself but I think it
showed the floor within it and I'm kind
of hoping that people see this and start
thinking
well I'm not gonna let Rotten Tomatoes
decide whether I see a film or like it
or not and just kind of go with my gut
go off the marketing and if it looks
good nothing I'm gonna enjoy it I'm
gonna go see it instead of being like
what I often do which is I'm excited for
this movie
trailer looks great gonna go see it oh
crap the Rotten Tomatoes score is bad
I'm not gonna bother now yeah I think I
think even the it's most people hey they
go they yeah they go off the score
or B they do a quick run through on the
capsules and the capsules are not
film it's not film criticism it's not
like film criticism is is a whole movie
review going into the different subjects
and you can find the gray see what they
like or dislike and
I don't know who chooses because I'm not
on Robin to me I'm not a verified person
on Rotten Tomatoes so I don't I don't
know exactly how the quote comes to be
for if it's a rotten or fresh one of if
Rotten Tomatoes chooses it or if the
reviewer themselves chooses that
specific line that they said because
sometimes it's not you know a written
review submit it is a like a YouTube
video like you might see stuckman's
appear on there and it's or or Grace
Randolph you might see her name appear
there and it's not a written thing it's
something from her video says I don't
know how that's decided
but then a lot of people will say that
that is their review based off that and
I've heard so many people also
um Express that they actually didn't
they leaned towards not liking it but
for some reason on Rotten Tomatoes it's
giving it afresh and I've also heard the
vice versa flip of that happen as well
you know so yeah I don't think it's as
reliable but the the the the bottom line
is that yeah they do the studios do
really rely on this I mean I have I have
found I mainly go to AMC Theaters so I
have an app for that I got my monthly
membership when I go to the theaters but
the the alternative for General movie
theaters out here I don't know what it's
like for you in the UK we have Fandango
and Fandango every movie there because I
think they're associated with I don't I
don't know and anyone can correct me if
they've gone into this part in the video
I think there's something about them
being associated with Warner Brothers
because Warner Brothers I think owns
Rotten Tomatoes
the minor shareholder I think yeah it's
it's already super sketchy to know that
it's already like super suspicious to
hear that
um but when you go to Fandango every
movie has the Rotten Tomatoes just the
score right uh listed to it so to help
you make your decision based off of that
so it is influential and I agree with uh
every every single point you said and
even for the Disney Plus shows it's
interesting because I think they're the
no I think maybe HBO does the movie I'm
not sure but Disney plus they for their
big shows
it's so much relies on it
take Ahsoka as our latest one for
example where the people who are giving
the early reactions are not going off of
the screeners they went to the movie
theaters and they're getting to
experience this with a big crowd on the
big screen you know so they're more
likely to have a completely different
experience and I like the first two
episodes of Ahsoka uh the first one were
in the second
they're more likely to have a completely
more effective experience because of the
that that bond that you you can only get
in a movie in a dark movie theater right
with a crowd feeling the energy and the
fans cheering whenever Rebels characters
come on screen and all that you know so
right then and there I don't know how
much
is I I I'm like I believe
that they will do that though obviously
to make it easier to get the early
social media reactions because they
can't control the score as much as they
try to manipulate It ultimately the
score is going to become what the score
is going to become unless you got a
bunker or 15 situation right the score
will ultimately does like quantumania
was all right at first and then it went
went way down but what that's where I
think they actually why Studios will try
to really utilize influencers so why you
see influencers go to these screenings
and stuff A lot of times you'll see
people going on I don't get why this
influencer gets to go but I don't get a
go and I'm a Critic like why does this
influencer because they're I think
they're hoping that the early social
media reactions will help combat what
Rotten Tomatoes has to say it's bringing
it back to that earlier point of what we
were talking about with the social media
reactions being manipulative it's just
another element of the marketing it
really is I think that's you know I
completely ignore social media reactions
now the early ones I just think you
rarely going to read a negative one out
of those and it can be used to people
getting such arguments over films that
they haven't seen like look this well
look all the reactions are good so it's
definitely going to be amazing it's like
mate you've got no idea and I've had
people argue with me who haven't seen a
movie about how good it is when I've
seen it and I didn't like it and I'm
like yeah but my opinion's actually
based on something like I understand it
it I feel like if you haven't seen it
how can you why should I rely on your
opinion at all it's like me asking you
what the weather is like outside and you
haven't even looked outside you give me
information that I just can't understand
and yeah it's kind of just evolved
criticism into yes something stupid
um I do think though that people get to
choose whether it's rotten or fresh I'm
pretty sure that when you're filling out
the review you can decide that at the
end for yourself
I remember hearing uh I believe it was
Chris stuckman I remember hearing talk
about that
um that that was one time where that
actually happened to him
um yeah they must have fixed it along to
it yeah yeah and I mean it's it's
another system as well where there's
gonna constantly be changes to it and
there'll be problems flagged and it's
not something that's even necessarily
holds up to scrutiny and this exposure
coming out I mean
I'd be surprised if there wasn't more
stuff coming out I think it might hit
the point where critics are like well
I've been approached by this to give a
positive review for something but
whether that's the case or not you know
we're playing it in conspiracy theories
which we said we wouldn't do and just in
general I think you know Rotten Tomatoes
and the way the media works at the
moment they sensationalize things so
people didn't even read the story and
kind of took their own thing from it and
we've kind of gone off on on that
ourselves
um and yeah everything just gets boiled
down to very simple terms whether it's
the Rotten Tomatoes score headline
journalism and there's just no more
Nuance anymore and I hope you guys you
know use you use your Noggin check this
stuff out don't even listen to me just
look into it for yourself decide if you
think a movie's good we talked about
Disney what came out at the I don't know
anything about what happened yeah d23 is
it something come out moving on to the
next subject which is D20 three
um Ryan Airy we're all in a big group
chat it's the a-listers of YouTube it's
me it's ryanairy it's Philip Molino used
to be on new rock stars worked with Mr
Beast you know we've got the big names
in there Greg's in there as well we'll
say um and Ryan was talking about d23
and I was like holy crap it's d23 today
I was like I'm not even not even ready
I'm not mentally prepared for this
um yeah and as he was saying that the
Disney presentation had just began and
I realized about 10 minutes in this
hasn't actually been hyped up at all so
I don't think it's going to be something
pretty big now normally in in the last
couple of years d23 has been almost like
a second Comic-Con yeah and we've been
we've gone in the build up to it there's
even been videos talking about what
potentially could be announced and
there's been I'm sure the Star Wars
slate when there was that big thing
where Kathleen Kennedy came out and she
did a big talk about like Rogue
squadrons coming out him make sure you
keep an eye out for that stuff like that
that all got announced there
um I think anyway but there's always
these kind of announcements because they
have like the Disney investor days where
they would have some announcements yeah
and then they have d23
and then they barely see yeah they don't
really attend Comic-Con yeah it's
but no d20th you're right d23 is
essentially like that's that that's like
we own this this is our Comic-Con you
know yeah and to see it drop like that
quite hit with anxiety and then realize
uh actually it's probably not going to
be that big um so we're gonna go through
what was actually announced there or not
announced there and but it was a very
low key event now I have I did put this
out saying where the hell is all the
hype gone and I was told that it's every
two years that it's the big d23 and then
for some reason in the middle they have
um uh more downplayed yeah where stuff's
not as hyped up which to me is a bit
weird I don't know why you call it the
same thing because I'm going in with
Xbox I'm waking up panicking going up
crap I've got no editors at work today
I'm gonna have to cover a whole event
because covering covering these whole
events guys you know I'll get panicked
when one trailer is dropping when you
hear it's a d23 you're thinking oh crap
there's gonna be five trailers dropping
yeah it'll be up all night working uh so
yeah a bit panicked here in that but
it started off with basically uh an
upcoming look at once upon a studio kind
of going through all of the things that
were coming because Disney's at 100
years right now so that they're
celebrating that and it just featured
lots of their characters and then they
went into a showcase for Ahsoka and this
is where things kind of went awry now
obviously there's a strike going on at
the moment so they couldn't necessarily
get actors involved to help come out and
promote it so guess who came on stage
scabbing for Ahsoka it was Chopper the
Droid
comes on stage instead of the cast and
he starts uh starts giving it the big
and beeping and popping now the next
showcase so obviously they talked about
Ahsoka they didn't show anything in
regards to episode 5 or anything or talk
about what's coming though episode 5 is
meant to be quite big because we are
getting Cinema screenings for it yeah
which is I'm guessing they're thinking
it's going to be a big event that's cool
yeah but yeah so yeah Chopper and then
from after that Haunted Mansion uh we
had some ghosts dancing on stage so
again got no actors but uh that releases
on October 4th on Disney plus okay and
then that was followed by Marvel's
showcase now this is where me and Ryan
Aries start panicking we still nothing
in is Echo is the Echo trailer going to
get dropped is the What If trailer gonna
get dropped they might show some footage
from Deadpool three we're still going oh
no it was gonna the next couple of hours
are gonna be manic uh so we got a
Showcase of I am Groot obviously season
two's just dropped oh yeah Greg I
realize I'm group it's the first Marvel
project I've not reviewed or done a
breakdown on
music I don't care yeah me me too oh
damn don't care anymore don't care
um so yeah first ever I even got crude
on my shirt right now damn man yeah okay
I'm sure kids enjoyed it and then we had
a new look at Loki season two where
apparently the first 10 minutes of the
the first episode was shown and but we
didn't get to see it then a new look at
the Marvels was showcased and uh then
they went from the Marvel panel into
wish which was shown and I think they
had some stuff talking about wish and
that was pretty that was pretty much it
so they showed the first 10 minutes of
Disney's wish as well
um and that was the panel now
no one there's been no buzz around it
unfortunately
um whether that's due to the actors not
being able to promote it or just the
lack of a lineup I know people were
saying you know it's set it's they have
a good year and they purposely have a
bad year in between but I still feel
like they brought out some stuff here
that you would think people would talk
about and care about like the Loki yeah
people are very hyped for that the
Marvels it's it's difficult to gauge
what hype's like with the Marvels I mean
everyone I speak to saying that saying
they're not that bothered but apparently
it's one of the most hyped up films of
the Year according to Fandango or
something
um so yeah a bit of a weird move by
by Disney it kind of underplay this and
it's just a good example to me of what
happens when Studios don't pay their
actors I know there's lots of people
going well they get paid too much but
you see the hype around this and you
kind of realize um and I actually ended
up halfway through the Marvel showcase I
just ended up going I'm gonna take the
kids for a walk which if you told me
three years ago d23 you're gonna leave
your desk and go out and do something
and have fun I would have thought
there's no way I'm having for there's no
way I'm spending quality time with
anyone I'm gonna be at work that day it
just it feels like everything's kind of
getting downplayed I mean when when you
need Chopper on stage and dancers for
Haunted Mansion it's kind of I feel like
you've almost hit a wall with it um and
just in general I just feel like well we
were talking about this today a lot of
this stuff and in the lineup just feels
like an obligation yeah I'm gonna go see
the Marvels because I want to know what
happens next time rather than being like
Oh there's a Marvel movie coming you
know I'm not
yeah that massive feeling of
excitement's not there it's more kind of
like I'm obligated to go see it because
one for my job in two because I would
just want to keep up to date with what's
happening with Marvel I mean for you to
not even react to a trailer from d23 is
pretty crazy I didn't know
any of what you just said until I heard
it is so I was like I I just I wasn't
until you message like oh yeah the d23
thing I totally forgot that that was a
thing that happened
um
wow none of that is exciting not not any
of that I've heard I hear they're really
hoping wish will be good
that's all I really know about that
movie I I hear good things and
man I got like no opinion on this I got
like no feeling this is just sad it's
really sad yeah because I think d23 what
was last year's d23 I remember that was
like kind of a big day I remember doing
a lot I was busy I was really busy that
day they were announcing [__] we thought
we'd get Deadpool announcement but then
they held off on that until like a
couple weeks later but there was like
other stuff yeah I'm sure that was the
Mandalorian season 3 trailer got
released online yes I'm sure a secret
Invasion got released online the the
wolf movie [__] what the hell is that
Marvel one I loved it um why can't I
call the name
yeah we'll find out yeah yeah
um yeah I love that come on uh yeah I
think that's when they had that trailer
too it was that that and maybe something
else but um yeah and according to so um
d23 for lucasfilm was Indiana Jones and
or Mandalorian bad batch tales of the
Jedi Skeleton Crew Willow and Ahsoka so
it was a pretty big year for lucasfilm
that was yeah that's right that was
really busy that day yeah yeah so
um Marvel 2022 was quantumania Black
Panther wakanda forever uh Thunderbolts
were also talked about and werewolf by
night so yeah I mean it was a pretty big
year last year
um yeah no just don't get armor Wars as
well and they talked about Fantastic
Four Captain America new world order as
well Loki season 2 ironheart and yeah
that was pretty big
um so I don't know why they just didn't
give it a different name because when I
hear d23 I'm sure you're in the same
headspace as me where you're like oh
crap it's the big end about how I make
loads of videos and trailers and
everything and so yeah just kind of
speaks to his state of how I feel Disney
or at the moment where it's not really
that much interest they've kind of
killed everything almost and yeah it's
kind of just another film rather than
being an event they're having a shitty
year I think all around they've had a
couple of Guardians three did good I'll
get it all the way guard is really good
Elemental group it seems like it's doing
actually really well on video on demand
um I feel like there's one more so that
I'll totally missing a Little Mermaid
did all right I think but not the
numbers that they expected it to do
um
yeah but you know Indiana Jones probably
one of the biggest bombs of all time
though quantumania lost a lot of money
and that's the kick Kickstart to their
phase five and
oh God Haunted Mansion terrible
yeah no I think they I mean I think just
between the money they lost from Indiana
Jones
and uh and uh juanamania is bad enough
as it is and then of course like their
shows I mean Ahsoka seems if if they're
putting Ahsoka in the theaters it must
be doing all right right it must be
doing good because the samba numbers
were like this ain't good but it might
actually be doing all right unless it's
just some
clever ploy to make it look like it's
doing all right but I feel like it would
just cost them so much more money if if
it actually wasn't doing well enough to
Warrant going to the cinemas for it I
guess we'll see what the what the sales
are like you know for it uh yeah yeah I
mean it it's uh and they actually
released the Ms Marvel viewing figures
on a you know so Ms Marvel's been pushed
to ABC to kind of um
bump up the the interest for the
Marvel's coming and it did really really
badly I was looking at the viewing
figures before and it didn't even crack
a million now granted it's been out for
a while
but you know I think it was Mr hu said
it was getting like less used than a
rerun of like Shark Tank or something oh
Jesus and yeah
it's not it's not doing good
um and that's obviously something they
need for the people to get interested in
the Marvels now speaking of comic book
films that everyone's interested in
Aquaman 2 dropped a teaser trailer for
the trailer so there was actually a
report that came out yesterday that said
Warner Brothers were spending absolutely
no money on marketing for this film they
were just gonna dump it yeah and then it
feels like they just threw this together
last minute and we're like let's put
let's put it out teaser trailers coming
Thursday guys you're gonna you're gonna
bloody love it
um and I kind of feel like again talking
about obligations I feel like Warner
Brothers releasing this it's kind of
like when you get asked to do the dishes
by your wife you know you do it but
you're not really enthusiastic about it
but you want to make it look like you've
made an effort and you are doing what
you've said but it's very much just like
I'm doing the bare minimum here just to
make it look like I care about doing
these dishes because I don't want to
annoy someone and that's kind of how it
feels
um the movie's less than 100 days out
and there just seems like no hype for it
like I think it's absolutely I mean
we're gonna see in the end how much it
makes but I think it's absolutely crazy
that Warner Brothers had a billion
dollar franchise in Aquaman that was a
spin-off of a main franchise that has
generated billions of dollars and
they've managed to tank both of them uh
to the point that no one cares it really
should be studied how how badly they've
managed to screw this up and but we got
some some teasers in it what did you
think of it Greg did you watch it I was
I I yeah I think I watched it uh I'm
pretty sure I've watched it um
I think I saw it like like
um on my phone with a red light on
because I was like oh I'm tired and so I
keep I have I have like a red light
thing to help me go to sleep so whatever
um
which I I and I saw screenshots of it
like him riding the seahorse and
whatever and uh I
I think it looks I think it was fine I'm
not I'm not the best judge if I'm kind
of waiting for the full trailer who was
standing out to me was it didn't seem to
do much hype on social media even there
is a time where even these 30 second
trailers about a trailer coming would
still be a big hype thing and before
film I don't know what it's at now but
right before filming it we checked and
even on YouTube it didn't even it's not
even close to a million views at this
point you know and it's been out for
almost 24 hours that's not a good sign
and I feel like the real Telltale sign
of how this movie is going to do
is going to be dependent
way more than Rotten Tomatoes I feel
like it's gonna be really dependent
right now on what that first trailer is
because this first trailer has to look
like [__] phenomenal it like bottom
line like no questions asked it can't
just be like oh yeah it kind of looks
like the first one but you know slightly
better it looks it looks like we're
gonna be underwater more and and as I'm
trying to provide more of that I think
the thing is they're going for this more
like epic harrowing heavy Stakes thing
and like the vibe in the mood what I
remember from that 30 seconds but it's
hard to feel that when you kind of feel
like DC has been telling me that this
franchise specifically specifically like
the aqua management is probably going to
be inconsequential in the end
so is there really a point in
experiencing this can I really feel the
weight that you're trying to pitch me
here because I I'm gonna watch it
obviously I'm gonna watch the damn movie
uh I'm gonna I'm gonna go see it you got
my money already it's a guarantee uh but
again this comes down to like bigger
audiences I feel like Aquaman has a good
uh International appeal like this kind
of fantasy film these kind of movies I
would probably do like really I think
what helped push it over the the line to
a billion was it's a phenomenal
performance in China and if they can get
that again you know I think this would
actually
this could do really well so yeah I
think internationally it'll do great I
don't know what it'll do like
domestically
and
we'll see we'll see what happens when
they put Amber Heard in that trailer and
then if that overshadows the whole
conversation even if she's there for
just one second you know there's gonna
be that voice of everyone in the
comments right yeah so we'll we'll see I
mean I'm I'm at the end of the day
though I gotta admit like at the end of
the day I I'm not I don't have the most
faith that it's going to do well
I really do hope that it is a good movie
though I I can't help but like root for
as I love James Juan there's so many of
his movies that I just absolutely adore
I love James Juan I like Jason Momoa the
for I wasn't a huge fan of that first
one I thought it looked cool but I
really wasn't a big fan of that story I
was even trying to recall like what
happened at the end again when I was
watching this trailer so
I you know I
I'm kind of I'm just kind of whatever
about it it's it's it's a bit of a
bummer I should watch the 30 seconds
again but you know maybe the maybe the
maybe the full trailer will just have a
completely different impact and uh I'm
gonna go and open-minded and I'm I'm at
the end of the day I'm rooting for it
I'm still rooted for it
but I can't say I have faith
it's weird I'm a dichotomy ball that's
where I'm at I kind of feel like they've
robbed the whole obligation thing that
we were talking about before where I
just don't feel obligated to go and see
this because I don't know if it's gonna
matter and I don't really have that much
faith in
DC in general outside of the Batman and
Joker and stuff like that I think it's a
bit of a weird one and
yeah obviously you know Amber heard's a
big thing whatever you think of the
outcome of that trial I would say you
know she lost the trial and by the I
would say she personally from my point
of view I would say she lost in the
court of public opinion which I think is
a big determination on how this movie is
going to be received and whether you
agree or disagree or not um I think
that's how it's perceived and that might
affect the film might not but it's gonna
be like another
a thing where it's going to be difficult
to Market at least her position in this
film yeah and that I feel like that no
matter what happens it's always going to
get brought up like I did a video on
just the the teaser today because I kind
of wanted to test the war as not
intended to see how the trailer
breakdown was going to do and whether we
were going to put effort and resources
into covering on Thursday when it
releases fully and at the moment I don't
really feel like we're gonna because
there's not really that amount of hype
for it at least uh people coming to my
channel for it and I'd rather just spend
that time reviewing Return of the Jedi
or something
um and getting editors to work on that
so yeah we'll probably skip that I feel
like I talked about the movie Enough in
the teaser breakdown to kind of cover
our backs on that but even though Amber
Heard wasn't in the trailer the teaser
trailer at least it was still you know I
had to talk about in the video in the
comments or about that and it's just no
matter what they do amber heard's gonna
get brought up if she's not in the movie
enough if she is it's going to be a
topic of discussion that's probably
going to be a headache for someone in PR
trying to organize this
um yeah I just didn't really feel that
I don't feel like there's that interest
now to be fair this is a teaser trailer
personally I feel I should have just
held off and just dropped the trailer on
Thursday without any of the build up
because
the conversation going into it is
already kind of negative
um and obviously even before this there
was a nightmare situation with test
screenings and every test screening for
this film has gone down pretty badly and
there's been reports that them they've
done new edits to it and those have
actually been worse than what was
originally there and from what's rumored
about the film James won is apparently
Fed Up of his life because he's been
working on this film so long he's having
to constantly reshoot constantly change
things for example you know Ben Affleck
was added into the film say that that
was a really positive thing like oh
thank God
and then it was like oh no Ben Affleck's
been removed because the James Gunn's
taking over and the Apparently Michael
Keaton was originally in it and it's
almost like a what's the Wheel of
Fortune with a different Batman actor
name written on it and you spin the
wheel and depending on who who it lands
on that's who you're gonna have to film
with that weekend apparently James won
is just absolutely feather
um and you can kind of like understand
from his point of view anyway I mean if
you work on something for so long like
we have a very microcosm thing of
working on videos sometimes for a long
time and you just hit a point where like
I saw this I just release it just I'm
sick of it just get it out I've wanna
work on something else I can imagine
he's in a similar sort of boat to that
and yeah it's it's a bit of a weird film
there were talks that it was going to
get delayed
ah I just don't know I think I really do
think James Gunn you know DC films
weren't doing well the DC EU films
weren't doing well in general anyway and
then for James Gunn to kind of come out
and announce that none of it's really
gonna matter it kind of was almost like
a nail in the coffin maybe not the final
nail uh but definitely put a dampener on
these films and we've seen that in the
case of the Flash's box office blue
beetles box office shazam's box office
whether you know they were affected by
James Gunn's announcement we'll never
know for definite but it does feel like
it kind of hit those films it definitely
didn't have a positive impact on those
films I'll say
um whether it hurt them substantially or
not remains to be seen and that'll be
the case with Aquaman but
but it's just a weird it's a weird
situation just DC in general like do uh
yeah it doesn't look to me like it's
doing enough from the first film to
differentiate it and make me feel like I
have to go rush out and see because this
is something I've not seen before and
obviously everywhere it's a sequel you
know that I I actually do quite like the
first film but I know those people are
like it's okay it's kind of a Marvel
movie disguised as a DC film and yeah a
bit of a bit of a weird one Greg I don't
feel like um it's gonna necessarily do
wonders for Warner Brothers and it might
just top off what's been a bad year for
them yeah I mean like showing Black
Manta and him fighting I'm like I guess
I should be Hypes but
he didn't really leave that much of an
impression on me in that movie as as
something I'm like oh I'm hyped for them
to fight again when they've already
fought before you know
um it's like if they did Thor two like
the dark world and it was just oh Loki
versus Thor again you know and I'm sure
it'll be different because he's gonna be
like black man to in his prime and he
was just getting his feet wet no pun
intended uh with being black Mana in the
in the first one like it's kind of An
Origin tale for him as well so I I
understand there's all that story
context to it and there's going to be
additional things surrounding it of
course
um but yeah we'll see I don't know I got
really no more thoughts on it man to be
totally Frank with you you know I'm just
gonna wait
I feel yeah just in general it's kind of
it's a Star Wars Marvel and DC it's like
the studios are putting out like quite
good projects but the interest just
doesn't feel in it's like how did your
guys manage to do this just kill the
interest as much and I think um it's
going to be an interesting couple of
years you know Aquaman everyone's going
to be looking at that box office opening
weekend and seeing how it ranks amongst
the other DC films and I think you know
if it does badly because James guns
attached himself so much of these films
and almost used it as a sort of soft
reboot point from because let's be
honest from what the way perception is
at the moment it's not a hard reboot and
it's gonna include a lot of these things
I think if this comes out bad it's gonna
start the DCU off on a really bad foot
and whether you know the week after it
releases gun might come out and do a
statement saying look we're hard
rebooting it it's it's Superman Legacy
we're starting off at but does that give
you much faith in his management of the
property because it's like well
you know you've you've taken us down
this route of thinking this stuff was
going to be included and then at the
last moment when stuff's not done well
being like oh well it doesn't actually
matter anymore and it just kind of feels
like no matter what happens whether he
sticks to his guns or not intended or
stick or doesn't stick to his gun then
it's gonna go badly either way and yeah
Superman Legacy I think that in Deadpool
3 there is so much riding on both those
films I think Deadpool 3 if that's bad
I'll worry about the future of the MCU
if it's good I think you know we can
feel like it's a win and be like oh
thank God they managed to nail the the
X-Men these classic characters that
they're bringing over to the MCU thank
God that was good and Superman Legacy I
feel like it's the same situation with
DC for that if it does badly then
that entire chapter one Gods and
Monsters thing that is that is in
trouble from the off if it does good
it's going to give me hope that you know
James Gunn was the right person to put
in charge I'm gonna be so happy that
we're starting off in the right foot and
yeah a lot hinges on those two movies
that's kind of crazy because there's
like
people forget like it's not just oh
Disney and Warner Brothers these are
Studios like there's DC Studios and
Marvel Studios you know so if things
continue down like a negative path they
might shut down an action the actual
Studio departments for them and then
just have to
Just Produce it as like you know a
Disney movie if they want to continue
doing conflict movies or a Warner
Brothers movie and not be like DC
Studios and stuff so it is there's a lot
of there's a lot at stake here but we'll
see man we'll see
um yeah and that wraps up another
episode of across the spoilerverse
please guys if you guys are watching and
you on your phone or something
um hit the Thumbs Up Button if you're on
Apple podcasts or Spotify or Amazon
where we go if you're just in the app it
takes two seconds out your day it means
so much to us if you just go rate US
helps push the podcast and it means we
can bring you amazing episodes like this
forever and ever and ever and never have
to go back to doing any other type of
video so yeah thanks again for for
sitting with us guys we hope you're
enjoying your day thanks for including
us in it
um on which stories just below Greg's
over at real rejects if you want to go
check out his reactions and thoughts on
films and along with his buddies you've
got lots of big hosts on there and yeah
uh go check him out and thanks again for
for sticking with us Greg any final
thoughts no Paul I think I'm looking the
right way wrong way
that's where you're at I did I did The
Improv wrong I had a great time today
thank you Paul and thank all of you for
being here
much love